Good morning,
everyone.
Glad you are all here bright
and early.
I'm counting the days till the
TA's outnumber the students.
They'll show up.
We return to a familiar story.
This is part two,
the Empire Strikes Back.
So last time,
our adversary,
the graph, came to us with a
problem.
We have a source,
and we had a directed graph,
and we had weights on the
edges, and they were all
nonnegative.
And there was happiness.
And we triumphed over the
Empire by designing Dijkstra's
algorithm, and very efficiently
finding single source shortest
paths, shortest path weight from
s to every other vertex.
Today, however,
the Death Star has a new trick
up its sleeve,
and we have negative weights,
potentially.
And we're going to have to
somehow deal with,
in particular,
negative weight cycles.
And we saw that when we have a
negative weight cycle,
we can just keep going around,
and around, and around,
and go back in time farther,
and farther,
and farther.
And we can get to be
arbitrarily far back in the
past.
And so there's no shortest
path, because whatever path you
take you can get a shorter one.
So we want to address that
issue today, and we're going to
come up with a new algorithm
actually simpler than Dijkstra,
but not as fast,
called the Bellman-Ford
algorithm.
And, it's going to allow
negative weights,
and in some sense allow
negative weight cycles,
although maybe not as much as
you might hope.
We have to leave room for a
sequel, of course.
OK, so the Bellman-Ford
algorithm, invented by two guys,
as you might expect,
it computes the shortest path
weights.
So, it makes no assumption
about the weights.
Weights are arbitrary,
and it's going to compute the
shortest path weights.
So, remember this notation:
delta of s, v is the weight of
the shortest path from s to v.
s was called a source vertex.
And, we want to compute these
weights for all vertices,
little v.
The claim is that computing
from s to everywhere is no
harder than computing s to a
particular location.
So, we're going to do for all
them.
It's still going to be the case
here.
And, it allows negative
weights.
And this is the good case,
but there's an alternative,
which is that Bellman-Ford may
just say, oops,
there's a negative weight
cycle.
And in that case it will just
say so.
So, they say a negative weight
cycle exists.
Therefore, some of these deltas
are minus infinity.
And that seems weird.
So, Bellman-Ford as we'll
present it today is intended for
the case, but there are no
negative weights cycles,
which is more intuitive.
It sort of allows them,
but it will just report them.
In that case,
it will not give you delta
values.
You can change the algorithm to
give you delta values in that
case, but we are not going to
see it here.
So, in exercise,
after you see the algorithm,
exercise is:
compute these deltas in all
cases.
So, it's not hard to do.
But we don't have time for it
here.
So, here's the algorithm.
It's pretty straightforward.
As I said, it's easier than
Dijkstra.
It's a relaxation algorithm.
So the main thing that it does
is relax edges just like
Dijkstra.
So, we'll be able to use a lot
of dilemmas from Dijkstra.
And proof of correctness will
be three times shorter because
the first two thirds we already
have from Dijkstra.
But I'm jumping ahead a bit.
So, the first part is
initialization.
Again, d of v will represent
the estimated distance from s to
v.
And we're going to be updating
those estimates as the algorithm
goes along.
And initially,
d of s is zero,
which now may not be the right
answer conceivably.
Everyone else is infinity,
which is certainly an upper
bound.
OK, these are both upper bounds
on the true distance.
So that's fine.
That's initialization just like
before.
And now we have a main loop
which happens v minus one times.
We're not actually going to use
the index i.
It's just a counter.
And we're just going to look at
every edge and relax it.
It's a very simple idea.
If you learn about relaxation,
this is the first thing you
might try.
The question is when do you
stop.
It's sort of like I have this
friend to what he was like six
years old he would claim,
oh, I know how to spell banana.
I just don't know when to stop.
OK, same thing with relaxation.
This is our relaxation step
just as before.
We look at the edge;
we see whether it violates the
triangle inequality according to
our current estimates we know
the distance from s to v should
be at most distance from s to
plus the weight of that edge
from u to v.
If it isn't,
we set it equal.
We've proved that this is
always an OK thing to do.
We never violate,
I mean, these d of v's never
get too small if we do a bunch
of relaxations.
So, the idea is you take every
edge.
You relax it.
I don't care which order.
Just relax every edge,
one each.
And that do that V minus one
times.
The claim is that that should
be enough if you have no
negative weights cycles.
So, if there's a negative
weight cycle,
we need to figure it out.
And, we'll do that in a fairly
straightforward way,
which is we're going to do
exactly the same thing.
So this is outside before loop
here.
We'll have the same four loops
for each edge in our graph.
We'll try to relax it.
And if you can relax it,
the claim is that there has to
be a negative weight cycle.
So this is the main thing that
needs proof.
OK, and that's the algorithm.
So the claim is that at the
ends we should have d of v,
let's see, L's so to speak.
d of v equals delta of s comma
v for every vertex,
v.
If we don't find a negative
weight cycle according to this
rule, that we should have all
the shortest path weights.
That's the claim.
Now, the first question is,
in here, the running time is
very easy to analyze.
So let's start with the running
time.
We can compare it to Dijkstra,
which is over here.
What is the running time of
this algorithm?
V times E, exactly.
OK, I'm going to assume,
because it's pretty reasonable,
that V and E are both positive.
Then it's V times E.
So, this is a little bit
slower, or a fair amount slower,
than Dijkstra's algorithm.
There it is:
E plus V log V is essentially,
ignoring the logs is pretty
much linear time.
Here we have something that's
at least quadratic in V,
assuming your graph is
connected.
So, it's slower,
but it's going to handle these
negative weights.
Dijkstra can't handle negative
weights at all.
So, let's do an example,
make it clear why you might
hope this algorithm works.
And then we'll prove that it
works, of course.
But the proof will be pretty
easy.
So, I'm going to draw a graph
that has negative weights,
but no negative weight cycles
so that I get an interesting
answer.
Good.
The other thing I need in order
to make the output of this
algorithm well defined,
it depends in which order you
visit the edges.
So I'm going to assign an
arbitrary order to these edges.
I could just ask you for an
order, but to be consistent with
the notes, I'll put an ordering
on it.
Let's say I put number four,
say that's the fourth edge I'll
visit.
It doesn't matter.
But it will affect what happens
during the algorithm for a
particular graph.
Do they get them all?
One, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven, eight,
OK.
And my source is going to be A.
And, that's it.
So, I want to run this
algorithm.
I'm just going to initialize
everything.
So, I set the estimates for s
to be zero, and everyone else to
be infinity.
And to give me some notion of
time, over here I'm going to
draw or write down what all of
these d values are as the
algorithm proceeds because I'm
going to start crossing them out
and rewriting them that the
figure will get a little bit
messier.
But we can keep track of it
over here.
It's initially zero and
infinities.
Yeah?
It doesn't matter.
So, for the algorithm you can
go to the edges in a different
order every time if you want.
We'll prove that,
but here I'm going to go
through the same order every
time.
Good question.
It turns out it doesn't matter
here.
OK, so here's the starting
point.
Now I'm going to relax every
edge.
So, there's going to be a lot
of edges here that don't do
anything.
I try to relax n minus one.
I'd say, well,
I know how to get from s to B
with weight infinity.
Infinity plus two I can get to
from s to E.
Well, infinity plus two is not
much better than infinity.
OK, so I don't do anything,
don't update this to infinity.
I mean, infinity plus two
sounds even worse.
But infinity plus two is
infinity.
OK, that's the edge number one.
So, no relaxation edge number
two, same deal as number three,
same deal, edge number four we
start to get something
interesting because I have a
finite value here that says I
can get from A to B using a
total weight of minus one.
So that seems good.
I'll write down minus one here,
and update B to minus one.
The rest stay the same.
So, I'm just going to keep
doing this over and over.
That was edge number four.
Number five,
we also get a relaxation.
Four is better than infinity.
So, c gets a number of four.
Then we get to edge number six.
That's infinity plus five is
worse than four.
OK, so no relaxation there.
Edge number seven is
interesting because I have a
finite value here minus one plus
the weight of this edge,
which is three.
That's a total of two,
which is actually better than
four.
So, this route,
A, B, c is actually better than
the route I just found a second
ago.
So, this is now a two.
This is all happening in one
iteration of the main loop.
We actually found two good
paths to c.
We found one better than the
other.
OK, and that was edge number
seven, and edge number eight is
over here.
It doesn't matter.
OK, so that was round one of
this outer loop,
so, the first value of i.
i equals one.
OK, now we continue.
Just keep going.
So, we start with edge number
one.
Now, minus one plus two is one.
That's better than infinity.
It'll start speeding up.
It's repetitive.
It's actually not too much
longer until we're done.
Number two, this is an infinity
so we don't do anything.
Number three:
minus one plus two is one;
better than infinity.
This is vertex d,
and it's number three.
Number four we've already done.
Nothing changed.
Number five:
this is where we see the path
four again, but that's worse
than two.
So, we don't update anything.
Number six: one plus five is
six, which is bigger than two,
so no good.
Go around this way.
Number seven:
same deal.
Number eight is interesting.
So, we have a weight of one
here, a weight of minus three
here.
So, the total is minus two,
which is better than one.
So, that was d.
And, I believe that's it.
So that was definitely the end
of that round.
So, it's I plus two because we
just looked at the eighth edge.
And, I'll cheat and check.
Indeed, that is the last thing
that happens.
We can check the couple of
outgoing edges from d because
that's the only one whose value
just changed.
And, there are no more
relaxations possible.
So, that was in two rounds.
The claim is we got all the
shortest path weights.
The algorithm would actually
loop four times to guarantee
correctness because we have five
vertices here and one less than
that.
So, in fact,
in the execution here there are
two more blank rounds at the
bottom.
Nothing happens.
But, what the hell?
OK, so that is Bellman-Ford.
I mean, it's certainly not
doing anything wrong.
The question is,
why is it guaranteed to
converge in V minus one steps
unless there is a negative
weight cycle?
Question?
Right, so that's an
optimization.
If you discover a whole round,
and nothing happens,
so you can keep track of that
in the algorithm thing,
you can stop.
In the worst case,
it won't make a difference.
But in practice,
you probably want to do that.
Yeah?
Good question.
All right, so some simple
observations,
I mean, we're only doing
relaxation.
So, we can use a lot of our
analysis from before.
In particular,
the d values are only
decreasing monotonically.
As we cross out values here,
we are always making it
smaller, which is good.
Another nifty thing about this
algorithm is that you can run it
even in a distributed system.
If this is some actual network,
some computer network,
and these are machines,
and they're communicating by
these links, I mean,
it's a purely local thing.
Relaxation is a local thing.
You don't need any global
strategy, and you're asking
about, can we do a different
order in each step?
Well, yeah, you could just keep
relaxing edges,
and keep relaxing edges,
and just keep going for the
entire lifetime of the network.
And eventually,
you will find shortest paths.
So, this algorithm is
guaranteed to finish in V rounds
in a distributed system.
It might be more asynchronous.
And, it's a little harder to
analyze.
But it will still work
eventually.
It's guaranteed to converge.
And so, Bellman-Ford is used in
the Internet for finding
shortest paths.
OK, so let's finally prove that
it works.
This should only take a couple
of boards.
So let's suppose we have a
graph and some edge weights that
have no negative weight cycles.
Then the claim is that we
terminate with the correct
answer.
So, Bellman-Ford terminates
with all of these d of v values
set to the delta values for
every vertex.
OK, the proof is going to be
pretty immediate using the
lemmas that we had from before
if you remember them.
So, we're just going to look at
every vertex separately.
So, I'll call the vertex v.
The claim is that this holds by
the end of the algorithm.
So, remember what we need to
prove is that at some point,
d of v equals delta of s comma
v because we know it decreases
monotonically,
and we know that it never gets
any smaller than the correct
value because relaxations are
always safe.
So, we just need to show at
some point this holds,
and that it will hold at the
end.
So, by monotonicity of the d
values, and by correctness part
one, which was that the d of v's
are always greater than or equal
to the deltas,
we only need to show that at
some point we have equality.
So that's our goal.
So what we're going to do is
just look at v,
and the shortest path to v,
and see what happens to the
algorithm relative to that path.
So, I'm going to name the path.
Let's call it p.
It starts at vertex v_0 and
goes to v_1, v_2,
whatever, and ends at v_k.
And, this is not just any
shortest path,
but it's one that starts at s.
So, v_0's s,
and it ends at v.
So, I'm going to give a couple
of names to s and v so I can
talk about the path more
uniformly.
So, this is a shortest path
from s to v.
Now, I also want it to be not
just any shortest path from s to
v, but among all shortest paths
from s to v I want it to be one
with the fewest possible edges.
OK, so shortest here means in
terms of the total weight of the
path.
Subject to being shortest in
weight, I wanted to also be
shortest in the number of edges.
And, the reason I want that is
to be able to conclude that p is
a simple path,
meaning that it doesn't repeat
any vertices.
Now, can anyone tell me why I
need to assume that the number
of edges is the smallest
possible in order to guarantee
that p is simple?
The claim is that not all
shortest paths are necessarily
simple.
Yeah?
Right, I can have a zero weight
cycle, exactly.
So, we are hoping,
I mean, in fact in the theorem
here, we're assuming that there
are no negative weight cycles.
But there might be zero weight
cycles still.
As a zero weight cycle,
you can put that in the middle
of any shortest path to make it
arbitrarily long,
repeat vertices over and over.
That's going to be annoying.
What I want is that p is
simple.
And, I can guarantee that
essentially by shortcutting.
If ever I take a zero weight
cycle, I throw it away.
And this is one mathematical
way of doing that.
OK, now what else do we know
about this shortest path?
Well, we know that subpaths are
shortest paths are shortest
paths.
That's optimal substructure.
So, we know what the shortest
path from s to v_i is sort of
inductively.
It's the shortest path,
I mean, it's the weight of that
path, which is,
in particular,
the shortest path from s to v
minus one plus the weight of the
last edge, v minus one to v_i.
So, this is by optimal
substructure as we proved last
time.
OK, and I think that's pretty
much the warm-up.
So, I want to sort of do this
inductively in I,
start out with v zero,
and go up to v_k.
So, the first question is,
what is d of v_0,
which is s?
What is d of the source?
Well, certainly at the
beginning of the algorithm,
it's zero.
So, let's say equals zero
initially because that's what we
set it to.
And it only goes down from
there.
So, it certainly,
at most, zero.
The real question is,
what is delta of s comma v_0.
What is the shortest path
weight from s to s?
It has to be zero,
otherwise you have a negative
weight cycle,
exactly.
My favorite answer,
zero.
So, if we had another path from
s to s, I mean,
that is a cycle.
So, it's got to be zero.
So, these are actually equal at
the beginning of the algorithm,
which is great.
That means they will be for all
time because we just argued up
here, only goes down,
never can get too small.
So, we have d of v_0 set to the
right thing.
Great: good for the base case
of the induction.
Of course, what we really care
about is v_k,
which is v.
So, let's talk about the v_i
inductively, and then we will
get v_k as a result.
So, yeah, let's do it by
induction.
That's more fun.
Let's say that d of v_i is
equal to delta of s v_i after I
rounds of the algorithm.
So, this is actually referring
to the I that is in the
algorithm here.
These are rounds.
So, one round is an entire
execution of all the edges,
relaxation of all the edges.
So, this is certainly true for
I equals zero.
We just proved that.
After zero rounds,
at the beginning of the
algorithm, d of v_0 equals delta
of s, v_0.
OK, so now, that's not really
what I wanted,
but OK, fine.
Now we'll prove it for d of v_i
plus one.
Generally, I recommend you
assume something.
In fact, why don't I follow my
own advice and change it?
It's usually nicer to think of
induction as recursion.
So, you assume that this is
true, let's say,
for j less than the i that you
care about, and then you prove
it for d of v_i.
It's usually a lot easier to
think about it that way.
In particular,
you can use strong induction
for all less than i.
Here, we're only going to need
it for one less.
We have some relation between I
and I minus one here in terms of
the deltas.
And so, we want to argue
something about the d values.
OK, well, let's think about
what's going on here.
We know that,
let's say, after I minus one
rounds, we have this inductive
hypothesis, d of v_i minus one
equals delta of s v_i minus one.
And, we want to conclude that
after i rounds,
so we have one more round to do
this.
We want to conclude that d of
v_i has the right answer,
delta of s comma v_i.
Does that look familiar at all?
So we want to relax every edge
in this round.
In particular,
at some point,
we have to relax the edge from
v_i minus one to v_i.
We know that this path consists
of edges.
That's the definition of a
path.
So, during the i'th round,
we relax every edge.
So, we better relax v_i minus
one v_i.
And, what happens then?
It's a test of memory.
Quick, the Death Star is
approaching.
So, if we have the correct
value for v_i minus one,
that we relax an outgoing edge
from there, and that edge is an
edge of the shortest path from s
to v_i.
What do we know?
d of v_i becomes the correct
value, delta of s comma v_i.
This was called correctness
lemma last time.
One of the things we proved
about Dijkstra's algorithm,
but it was really just a fact
about relaxation.
And it was a pretty simple
proof.
And it comes from this fact.
We know the shortest path
weight is this.
So, certainly d of v_i was at
least this big,
and let's suppose it's greater,
or otherwise we were done.
We know d of v_i minus one is
set to this.
And so, this is exactly the
condition that's being checked
in the relaxation step.
And, the d of v_i value will be
greater than this,
let's suppose.
And then, we'll set it equal to
this.
And that's exactly d of s v_i.
So, when we relax that edge,
we've got to set it to the
right value.
So, this is the end of the
proof, right?
It's very simple.
The point is,
you look at your shortest path.
Here it is.
And if we assume there's no
negative weight cycles,
this has the correct value
initially.
d of s is going to be zero.
After the first round,
you've got to relax this edge.
And then you get the right
value for that vertex.
After the second round,
you've got to relax this edge,
which gets you the right d
value for this vertex and so on.
And so, no matter which
shortest path you take,
you can apply this analysis.
And you know that by,
if the length of this path,
here we assumed it was k edges,
then after k rounds you've got
to be done.
OK, so this was not actually
the end of the proof.
Sorry.
So this means after k rounds,
we have the right answer for
v_k, which is v.
So, the only question is how
big could k be?
And, it better be the right
answer, at most,
v minus one is the claim by the
algorithm that you only need to
do v minus one steps.
And indeed, the number of edges
in a simple path in a graph is,
at most, the number of vertices
minus one.
k is, at most,
v minus one because p is
simple.
So, that's why we had to assume
that it wasn't just any shortest
path.
It had to be a simple one so it
didn't repeat any vertices.
So there are,
at most, V vertices in the
path, so at most,
V minus one edges in the path.
OK, and that's all there is to
Bellman-Ford.
So: pretty simple in
correctness.
Of course, we're using a lot of
the lemmas that we proved last
time, which makes it easier.
OK, a consequence of this
theorem, or of this proof is
that if Bellman-Ford fails to
converge, and that's what the
algorithm is checking is whether
this relaxation still requires
work after these d minus one
steps.
Right, the end of this
algorithm is run another round,
a V'th round,
see whether anything changes.
So, we'll say that the
algorithm fails to converge
after V minus one steps or
rounds.
Then, there has to be a
negative weight cycle.
OK, this is just a
contrapositive of what we
proved.
We proved that if you assume
there's no negative weight
cycle, then we know that d of s
is zero, and then all this
argument says is you've got to
converge after v minus one
rounds.
There can't be anything left to
do once you've reached the
shortest path weights because
you're going monotonically;
you can never hit the bottom.
You can never go to the floor.
So, if you fail to converge
somehow after V minus one
rounds, you've got to have
violated the assumption.
The only assumption we made was
there's no negative weight
cycle.
So, this tells us that
Bellman-Ford is actually
correct.
When it says that there is a
negative weight cycle,
it indeed means it.
It's true.
OK, and you can modify
Bellman-Ford in that case to
sort of run a little longer,
and find where all the minus
infinities are.
And that is,
in some sense,
one of the things you have to
do in your problem set,
I believe.
So, I won't cover it here.
But, it's a good exercise in
any case to figure out how you
would find where the minus
infinities are.
What are all the vertices
reachable from negative weight
cycle?
Those are the ones that have
minus infinities.
OK, so you might say,
well, that was awfully fast.
Actually, it's not over yet.
The episode is not yet ended.
We're going to use Bellman-Ford
to solve the even bigger and
greater shortest path problems.
And in the remainder of today's
lecture, we will see it applied
to a more general problem,
in some sense,
called linear programming.
And the next lecture,
we'll really use it to do some
amazing stuff with all pairs
shortest paths.
Let's go over here.
So, our goal,
although it won't be obvious
today, is to be able to compute
the shortest paths between every
pair of vertices,
which we could certainly do at
this point just by running
Bellman-Ford v times.
OK, but we want to do better
than that, of course.
And, that will be the climax of
the trilogy.
OK, today we just discovered
who Luke's father is.
So, it turns out the father of
shortest paths is linear
programming.
Actually, simultaneously the
father and the mother because
programs do not have gender.
OK, my father likes to say,
we both took improv comedy
lessons so we have degrees in
improvisation.
And he said,
you know, we went to improv
classes in order to learn how to
make our humor better.
And, the problem is,
it didn't actually make our
humor better.
It just made us less afraid to
use it.
[LAUGHTER] So,
you are subjected to all this
improv humor.
I didn't see the connection of
Luke's father,
but there you go.
OK, so, linear programming is a
very general problem,
a very big tool.
Has anyone seen linear
programming before?
OK, one person.
And, I'm sure you will,
at some time in your life,
do anything vaguely computing
optimization related,
linear programming comes up at
some point.
It's a very useful tool.
You're given a matrix and two
vectors: not too exciting yet.
What you want to do is find a
vector.
This is a very dry description.
We'll see what makes it so
interesting in a moment.
So, you want to maximize some
objective, and you have some
constraints.
And they're all linear.
So, the objective is a linear
function in the variables x,
and your constraints are a
bunch of linear constraints,
inequality constraints,
that's one makes an
interesting.
It's not just solving a linear
system as you've seen in linear
algebra, or whatever.
Or, of course,
it could be that there is no
such x.
OK: vaguely familiar you might
think to the theorem about
Bellman-Ford.
And, we'll show that there's
some kind of connection here
that either you want to find
something, or show that it
doesn't exist.
Well, that's still a pretty
vague connection,
but I also want to maximize
something, or are sort of
minimize the shortest paths,
OK, somewhat similar.
We have these constraints.
So, yeah.
This may be intuitive to you,
I don't know.
I prefer a more geometric
picture, and I will try to draw
such a geometric picture,
and I've never tried to do this
on a blackboard,
so it should be interesting.
I think I'm going to fail
miserably.
It sort of looks like a
dodecahedron,
right?
Sort of, kind of,
not really.
A bit rough on the bottom,
OK.
So, if you have a bunch of
linear constraints,
this is supposed to be in 3-D.
Now I labeled it.
It's now in 3-D.
Good.
So, you have these linear
constraints.
That turns out to define
hyperplanes in n dimensions.
OK, so you have this base here
that's three-dimensional space.
So, n equals three.
And, these hyperplanes,
if you're looking at one side
of the hyperplane,
that's the less than or equal
to, if you take the
intersection,
you get some convex polytope or
polyhedron.
In 3-D, you might get a
dodecahedron or whatever.
And, your goal,
you have some objective vector
c, let's say,
up.
Suppose that's the c vector.
Your goal is to find the
highest point in this polytope.
So here, it's maybe this one.
OK, this is the target.
This is the optimal,
x.
That is the geometric view.
If you prefer the algebraic
view, you want to maximize the c
transpose times x.
So, this is m.
This is n.
Check out the dimensions work
out.
So that's saying you want to
maximize the dot product.
You want to maximize the extent
to which x is in the direction
c.
And, you want to maximize that
subject to some constraints,
which looks something like
this, maybe.
So, this is A,
and it's m by n.
You want to multiply it by,
it should be something of
height n.
That's x.
Let me put x down here,
n by one.
And, it should be less than or
equal to something of this
height, which is B,
the right hand side.
OK, that's the algebraic view,
which is to check out all the
dimensions are working out.
But, you can read these off in
each row here,
when multiplied by this column,
gives you one value here.
And as just a linear
constraints on all the x sides.
So, you want to maximize this
linear function of x_1 up to x_n
subject to these constraints,
OK?
Pretty simple,
but pretty powerful in general.
So, it turns out that with,
you can formulate a huge number
of problems such as shortest
paths as a linear program.
So, it's a general tool.
And in this class,
we will not cover any
algorithms for solving linear
programming.
It's a bit tricky.
I'll just mention that they are
out there.
So, there's many efficient
algorithms, and lots of code
that does this.
It's a very practical setup.
So, lots of algorithms to solve
LP's, linear programs.
Linear programming is usually
called LP.
And, I'll mention a few of
them.
There's the simplex algorithm.
This is one of the first.
I think it is the first,
the ellipsoid algorithm.
There's interior point methods,
and there's random sampling.
I'll just say a little bit
about each of these because
we're not going to talk about
any of them in depth.
The simplex algorithm,
this is, I mean,
one of the first algorithms in
the world in some sense,
certainly one of the most
popular.
It's still used today.
Almost all linear programming
code uses the simplex algorithm.
It happens to run an
exponential time in the
worst-case, so it's actually
pretty bad theoretically.
But in practice,
it works really well.
And there is some recent work
that tries to understand this.
It's still exponential in the
worst case.
But, it's practical.
There's actually an open
problem whether there exists a
variation of simplex that runs
in polynomial time.
But, I won't go into that.
That's a major open problem in
this area of linear programming.
The ellipsoid algorithm was the
first algorithm to solve linear
programming in polynomial time.
So, for a long time,
people didn't know.
Around this time,
people started realizing
polynomial time is a good thing.
That happened around the late
60s.
Polynomial time is good.
And, the ellipsoid algorithm is
the first one to do it.
It's a very general algorithm,
and very powerful,
theoretically:
completely impractical.
But, it's cool.
It lets you do things like you
can solve a linear program that
has exponentially many
constraints in polynomial time.
You've got all sorts of crazy
things.
So, I'll just say it's
polynomial time.
I can't say something nice
about it; don't say it at all.
It's impractical.
Interior point methods are sort
of the mixture.
They run in polynomial time.
You can guarantee that.
And, they are also pretty
practical, and there's sort of
this competition these days
about whether simplex or
interior point is better.
And, I don't know what it is
today but a few years ago they
were neck and neck.
And, random sampling is a brand
new approach.
This is just from a couple
years ago by two MIT professors,
Dimitris Bertsimas and Santosh
Vempala, I guess the other is in
applied math.
So, just to show you,
there's active work in this
area.
People are still finding new
ways to solve linear programs.
This is completely randomized,
and very simple,
and very general.
It hasn't been implemented,
so we don't know how practical
it is yet.
But, it has potential.
OK: pretty neat.
OK, we're going to look at a
somewhat simpler version of
linear programming.
The first restriction we are
going to make is actually not
much of a restriction.
But, nonetheless we will
consider it, it's a little bit
easier to think about.
So here, we had some polytope
we wanted to maximize some
objective.
In a feasibility problem,
I just want to know,
is the polytope empty?
Can you find any point in that
polytope?
Can you find any set of values,
x, that satisfy these
constraints?
OK, so there's no objective.
c, just find x such that AX is
less than or equal to B.
OK, it turns out you can prove
a very general theorem that if
you can solve linear
feasibility, you can also solve
linear programming.
We won't prove that here,
but this is actually no easier
than the original problem even
though it feels easier,
and it's easier to think about.
I was just saying actually no
easier than LP.
OK, the next restriction we're
going to make is a real
restriction.
And it simplifies the problem
quite a bit.
And that's to look at different
constraints.
And, if all this seemed a bit
abstract so far,
we will now ground ourselves
little bit.
A system of different
constraints is a linear
feasibility problem.
So, it's an LP where there's no
objective.
And, it's with a restriction,
so, where each row of the
matrix, so, the matrix,
A, has one one,
and it has one minus one,
and everything else in the row
is zero.
OK, in other words,
each constraint has its very
simple form.
It involves two variables and
some number.
So, we have something like x_j
minus x_i is less than or equal
to w_ij.
So, this is just a number.
These are two variables.
There's a minus sign,
no values up here,
no coefficients,
no other of the X_k's appear,
just two of them.
And, you have a bunch of
constraints of this form,
one per row of the matrix.
Geometrically,
I haven't thought about what
this means.
I think it means the
hyperplanes are pretty simple.
Sorry I can't do better than
that.
It's a little hard to see this
in high dimensions.
But, it will start to
correspond to something we've
seen, namely the board that its
next to, very shortly.
OK, so let's do a very quick
example mainly to have something
to point at.
Here's a very simple system of
difference constraints --
-- OK, and a solution.
Why not?
It's not totally trivial to
solve this, but here's a
solution.
And the only thing to check is
that each of these constraints
is satisfied.
x_1 minus x_2 is three,
which is less than or equal to
three, and so on.
There could be negative values.
There could be positive values.
It doesn't matter.
I'd like to transform this
system of difference constraints
into a graph because we know a
lot about graphs.
So, we're going to call this
the constraint graph.
And, it's going to represent
these constraints.
How'd I do it?
Well, I take every constraint,
which in general looks like
this, and I convert it into an
edge.
OK, so if I write it as x_j
minus x_i is less than or equal
to some w_ij,
w seems suggestive of weights.
That's exactly why I called it
w.
I'm going to make that an edge
from v_i to v_j.
So, the order flips a little
bit.
And, the weight of that edge is
w_ij.
So, just do that.
Make n vertices.
So, you have the number of
vertices equals n.
The number of edges equals the
number of constraints,
which is m, the height of the
matrix, and just transform.
So, for example,
here we have three variables.
So, we have three vertices,
v_1, v_2, v_3.
We have x_1 minus x_2.
So, we have an edge from v_2 to
v_1 of weight three.
We have x_2 minus x_3.
So, we have an edge from v_3 to
v_2 of weight minus two.
And, we have x_1 minus x_3.
So, we have an edge from v_3 to
v_1 of weight two.
I hope I got the directions
right.
Yep.
So, there it is,
a graph: currently no obvious
connection to shortest paths,
right?
But in fact,
this constraint is closely
related to shortest paths.
So let me just rewrite it.
You could say,
well, an x_j is less than or
equal to x_i plus w_ij.
Or, you could think of it as
d[j] less than or equal to d[i]
plus w_ij.
This is a conceptual balloon.
Look awfully familiar?
A lot like the triangle
inequality, a lot like
relaxation.
So, there's a very close
connection between these two
problems as we will now prove.
So, we're going to have two
theorems.
And, they're going to look
similar to the correctness of
Bellman-Ford in that they talk
about negative weight cycles.
Here we go.
It turns out,
I mean, we have this constraint
graph.
It can have negative weights.
It can have positive weights.
It turns out what matters is if
you have a negative weight
cycle.
So, the first thing to prove is
that if you have a negative
weight cycle that something bad
happens.
OK, what could happen bad?
Well, we're just trying to
satisfy this system of
constraints.
So, the bad thing is that there
might not be any solution.
These constraints may be
infeasible.
And that's the claim.
The claim is that this is
actually an if and only if.
But first we'll proved the if.
If you have a negative weight
cycle, you're doomed.
The difference constraints are
unsatisfiable.
That's a more intuitive way to
say it.
In the LP world,
they call it infeasible.
But unsatisfiable makes a lot
more sense.
There's no way to assign the
x_i's in order to satisfy all
the constraints simultaneously.
So, let's just take a look.
Consider a negative weight
cycle.
It starts at some vertex,
goes through some vertices,
and at some point comes back.
I don't care whether it repeats
vertices, just as long as this
cycle, from v_1 to v_1 is a
negative weight cycle strictly
negative weight.
OK, and what I'm going to do is
just write down all the
constraints.
Each of these edges corresponds
to a constraint,
which must be in the set of
constraints because we had that
graph.
So, these are all edges.
Let's look at what they give
us.
So, we have an edge from v_1 to
v_2.
That corresponds to x_2 minus
x_1 is, at most,
something, w_12.
Then we have x_3 minus x_2.
That's the weight w_23,
and so on.
And eventually we get up to
something like x_k minus
x_(k-1).
That's this edge:
w_(k-1),k , and lastly we have
this edge, which wraps around.
So, it's x_1 minus x_k,
w_k1 if I've got the signs
right.
Good, so here's a bunch of
constraints.
What do you suggest I do with
them?
Anything interesting about
these constraints,
say, the left hand sides?
Sorry?
It sounded like the right word.
What was it?
Telescopes, yes,
good.
Everything cancels.
If I added these up,
there's an x_2 and a minus x_2.
There's a minus x_1 and an x_1.
There's a minus XK and an XK.
Everything here cancels if I
add up the left hand sides.
So, what happens if I add up
the right hand sides?
Over here I get zero,
my favorite answer.
And over here,
we get all the weights of all
the edges in the negative weight
cycle, which is the weight of
the cycle, which is negative.
So, zero is strictly less than
zero: contradiction.
Contradiction:
wait a minute,
we didn't assume anything that
was false.
So, it's not really a
contradiction in the
mathematical sense.
We didn't contradict the world.
We just said that these
constraints are contradictory.
In other words,
if you pick any values of the
x_i's, there is no way that
these can all be true because
that you would get a
contradiction.
So, it's impossible for these
things to be satisfied by some
real x_i's.
So, these must be
unsatisfiable.
Let's say there's no satisfying
assignment, a little more
precise, x_1 up to x_m,
no weights.
Can we satisfy those
constraints?
Because they add up to zero on
the left-hand side,
and negative on the right-hand
side.
OK, so that's an easy proof.
The reverse direction will be
only slightly harder.
OK, so, cool.
We have this connection.
So motivation is,
suppose you'd want to solve
these difference constraints.
And we'll see one such
application.
I Googled around for difference
constraints.
There is a fair number of
papers that care about
difference constraints.
And, they all use shortest
paths to solve them.
So, if we can prove a
connection between shortest
paths, which we know how to
compute, and difference
constraints, then we'll have
something cool.
And, next class will see even
more applications of difference
constraints.
It turns out they're really
useful for all pairs shortest
paths.
OK, but for now let's just
prove this equivalence and
finish it off.
So, the reverse direction is if
there's no negative weight cycle
in this constraint graph,
then the system better be
satisfiable.
The claim is that these
negative weight cycles are the
only barriers for finding a
solution to these difference
constraints.
I have this feeling somewhere
here.
I had to talk about the
constraint graph.
Good.
Satisfied, good.
So, here we're going to see a
technique that is very useful
when thinking about shortest
paths.
And, it's a bit hard to guess,
especially if you haven't seen
it before.
This is useful in problem sets,
and in quizzes,
and finals, and everything.
So, keep this in mind.
I mean, I'm using it to prove
this rather simple theorem,
but the idea of changing the
graph, so I'm going to call this
constraint graph G.
Changing the graph is a very
powerful idea.
So, we're going to add a new
vertex, s, or source,
use the source,
Luke, and we're going to add a
bunch of edges from s because
being a source,
it better be connected to some
things.
So, we are going to add a zero
weight edge, or weight zero edge
from s to everywhere,
so, to every other vertex in
the constraint graph.
Those vertices are called v_i,
v_1 up to v_n.
So, I have my constraint graph.
But I'll copy this one so I can
change it.
It's always good to backup your
work before you make changes,
right?
So now, I want to add a new
vertex, s, over here,
my new source.
I just take my constraint
graph, whatever it looks like,
add in weight zero edges to all
the other vertices.
Simple enough.
Now, what did I do?
What did you do?
Well, I have a candidate source
now which can reach all the
vertices.
So, shortest path from s,
hopefully, well,
paths from s exist.
I can get from s to everywhere
in weight at most zero.
OK, maybe less.
Could it be less?
Well, you know,
like v_2, I can get to it by
zero minus two.
So, that's less than zero.
So I've got to be a little
careful.
What if there's a negative
weight cycle?
Oh no?
Then there wouldn't be any
shortest paths.
Fortunately,
we assume that there's no
negative weight cycle in the
original graph.
And if you think about it,
if there's no negative weight
cycle in the original graph,
we add an edge from s to
everywhere else.
We're not making any new
negative weight cycles because
you can start at s and go
somewhere at a cost of zero,
which doesn't affect any
weights.
And then, you are forced to
stay in the old graph.
So, there can't be any new
negative weight cycles.
So, the modified graph has no
That's good because it also has
paths from s,
and therefore it also has
shortest paths from s.
The modified graph has no
negative weight because it
didn't before.
And, it has paths from s.
There's a path from s to every
vertex.
There may not have been before.
Before, I couldn't get from v_2
to v_3, for example.
Well, that's still true.
But from s I can get to
everywhere.
So, that means that this graph,
this modified graph,
has shortest paths.
Shortest paths exist from s.
In other words,
if I took all the shortest path
weights, like I ran Bellman-Ford
from s, then,
I would get a bunch of finite
numbers, d of v,
for every value,
for every vertex.
That seems like a good idea.
Let's do it.
So, shortest paths exist.
Let's just assign x_i to be the
shortest path weight from s to
v_i.
Why not?
That's a good choice for a
number, the shortest path weight
from s to v_i.
This is finite because it's
less than infinity,
and it's greater than minus
infinity, so,
some finite number.
That's what we need to do in
order to satisfy these
constraints.
The claim is that this is a
satisfying assignment.
Why?
Triangle inequality.
Somewhere here we wrote
triangle inequality.
This looks a lot like the
In fact, I think that's the end
of the proof.
Let's see here.
What we want to be true with
this assignment is that x_j
minus x_i is less than or equal
to w_ij whenever ij is an edge.
Or, let's say v_i,
v_j, for every such constraint,
so, for v_i,
v_j in the edge set.
OK, so what is this true?
Well, let's just expand it out.
So, x_i is this delta,
and x_j is some other delta.
So, we have delta of s,
vj minus delta of s_vi.
And, on the right-hand side,
well, w_ij, that was the weight
of the edge from I to J.
So, this is the weight of v_i
to v_j.
OK, I will rewrite this
slightly.
Delta s, vj is less than or
equal to delta s,
vi plus w of v_i,
v_j.
And that's the triangle
inequality more or less.
The shortest path from s to v_j
is, at most, shortest path from
s to v_i plus a particular path
from v_i to v_j,
namely the single edge v_i to
v_j.
This could only be longer than
the shortest path.
And so, that makes the
right-hand side bigger,
which makes this inequality
more true, meaning it was true
before.
And now it's still true.
And, that proves it.
This is true.
And, these were all equivalent
statements.
This we know to be true by
triangle inequality.
Therefore, these constraints
are all satisfied.
Magic.
I'm so excited here.
So, we've proved that having a
negative weight cycle is exactly
when these system of difference
constraints are unsatisfiable.
So, if we want to satisfy them,
if we want to find the right
answer to x, we run
Bellman-Ford.
Either it says,
oh, no negative weight cycle.
Then you are hosed.
Then, there is no solution.
But that's the best you could
hope to know.
Otherwise, it says,
oh, there was no negative
weight cycle,
and here are your shortest path
weights.
You just plug them in,
and bam, you have your x_i's
that satisfy the constraints.
Awesome.
Now, it wasn't just any graph.
I mean, we started with
constraints, algebra,
we converted it into a graph by
this transform.
Then we added a source vertex,
s.
So, I mean, we had to build a
graph to solve our problem,
very powerful idea.
Cool.
This is the idea of reduction.
You can reduce the problem you
want to solve into some problem
you know how to solve.
You know how to solve shortest
paths when there are no negative
weight cycles,
or find out that there is a
negative weight cycle by
Bellman-Ford.
So, now we know how to solve
difference constraints.
It turns out you can do even
more.
Bellman-Ford does a little bit
more than just solve these
constraints.
But first let me write down
what I've been jumping up and
down about.
The corollary is you can use
Bellman-Ford.
I mean, you make this graph.
Then you apply Bellman-Ford,
and it will solve your system
of difference constraints.
So, let me put in some numbers
here.
You have m difference
constraints.
And, you have n variables.
And, it will solve them in
order m times n time.
Actually, these numbers go up
slightly because we are adding n
edges, and we're adding one
vertex, but assuming all of
these numbers are nontrivial,
m is at least n.
It's order MN time.
OK, trying to avoid cases where
some of them are close to zero.
Good.
So, some other facts,
that's what I just said.
And we'll leave these as
exercises because they're not
too essential.
The main thing we need is this.
But, some other cool facts is
that Bellman-Ford actually
optimizes some objective
functions.
So, we are saying it's just a
feasibility problem.
We just want to know whether
these constraints are
satisfiable.
In fact, you can add a
particular objective function.
So, you can't give it an
arbitrary objective function,
but here's one of interest.
x_1 plus x_2 plus x_n,
OK, but not just that.
We have some constraints.
OK, this is a linear program.
I want to maximize the sum of
the x_i's subject to all the
x_i's being nonpositive and the
difference constraints.
So, this we had before.
This is fine.
We noticed at some point you
could get from s to everywhere
with cost, at most,
zero.
So, we know that in this
assignment all of the x_i's are
negative.
That's not necessary,
but it's true when you run
Bellman-Ford.
So if you solve your system
using Bellman-Ford,
which is no less general than
anything else,
you happen to get nonpositive
x_i's.
And so, subject to that
constraint, it actually makes
them is close to zero as
possible in the L1 norm.
In the sum of these values,
it tries to make the sum as
close to zero,
it tries to make the values as
small as possible in absolute
value in this sense.
OK, it does more than that.
It cooks, it cleans,
it finds shortest paths.
It also minimizes the spread,
the maximum over all i of x_i
minus the minimum over all i of
x_i.
So, I mean, if you have your
real line, and here are the
x_i's wherever they are.
It minimizes this distance.
And zero is somewhere over
here.
So, it tries to make the x_i's
as compact as possible.
This is actually the L infinity
norm, if you know stuff about
norms from your linear algebra
class.
OK, this is the L1 norm.
I think it minimizes every LP
norm.
Good, so let's use this for
something.
Yeah, let's solve a real
problem, and then we'll be done
for today.
Next class we'll see the really
cool stuff, the really cool
application of all of this.
For now, and we'll see a cool
but relatively simple
application, which is VLSI
layout.
We talked a little bit about
VLSI way back and divide and
conquer.
You have a bunch of chips,
or you want to arrange them,
and minimize some objectives.
So, here's a particular,
tons of problems that come out
of VLSI layout.
Here's one of them.
You have a bunch of features of
an integrated circuit.
You want to somehow arrange
them on your circuit without
putting any two of them too
close to each other.
You have some minimum
separation like at least they
should not get top of each
other.
Probably, you also need some
separation to put wires in
between, and so on,
so, without putting any two
features too close together.
OK, so just to give you an
idea, so I have some objects and
I'm going to be a little bit
vague about how this works.
You have some features.
This is stuff,
some chips, whatever.
We don't really care what their
shapes look like.
I just want to be able to move
them around so that the gap at
any point, so let me just think
about this gap.
This gap should be at least
some delta.
Or, I don't want to use delta.
Let's say epsilon,
good, small number.
So, I just need some separation
between all of my parts.
And for this problem,
I'm going to be pretty simple,
just say that the parts are
only allowed to slide
horizontally.
So, it's a one-dimensional
problem.
These objects are in 2-d,
or whatever,
but I can only slide them an x
coordinate.
So, to model that,
I'm going to look at the left
edge of every part and say,
well, these two left edges
should be at least some
separation.
So, I think of it as whatever
the distance is plus some
epsilon.
But, you know,
if you have some funky 2-d
shapes you have to compute,
well, this is a little bit too
close because these come into
alignment.
But, there's some constraint,
well, for any two pieces,
I could figure out how close
they can get.
They should get no closer.
So, I'm going to call this x_1.
I'll call this x_2.
So, we have some constraint
like x_2 minus x_1 is at least d
plus epsilon,
or whatever you compute that
weight to be.
OK, so for every pair of
pieces, I can do this,
compute some constraint on how
far apart they have to be.
And, now I'd like to assign
these x coordinates.
Right now, I'm assuming they're
just variables.
I want to slide these pieces
around horizontally in order to
compactify them as much as
possible so they fit in the
smallest chip that I can make
because it costs money,
and time, and everything,
and power, everything.
You always want your chip
small.
So, Bellman-Ford does that.
All right, so Bellman-Ford
solves these constraints because
it's just a bunch of difference
constraints.
And we know that they are
solvable because you could
spread all the pieces out
arbitrarily far.
And, it minimizes the spread,
minimizes the size of the chip
I need, a max of x_i minus the
min of x_i.
So, this is it maximizes
compactness, or minimizes size
of the chip.
OK, this is a one-dimensional
problem, so it may seem a little
artificial, but the two
dimensional problem is really
hard to solve.
And this is,
in fact, the best you can do
with a nice polynomial time
algorithm.
There are other applications if
you're scheduling events in,
like, a multimedia environment,
and you want to guarantee that
this audio plays at least two
seconds after this video,
but then there are things that
are playing at the same time,
and they have to be within some
gap of each other,
so, lots of papers about using
Bellman-Ford,
solve difference constraints to
enable multimedia environments.
OK, so there you go.
And next class we'll see more
applications of Bellman-Ford to
all pairs shortest paths.
Questions?
Great.